ALL RIGHT. SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER. UM
GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE HOLDING
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM
2100 IN THE SWING SPACE. I ASK
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BE PRESENT ROOM 2100
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
TODAY'S BILL. UH WE ARE. WE'RE
GONNA ACTUALLY PROCEED AS A
SUBCOMITTEE. I NOTICED THAT WE
HAVE 50% OF THE REPUBLICANS THAT
ARE HERE AND WE HAVE NOT REACHED
THAT LEVEL OF ATTENDANCE ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE. UM YEAH. I WANT
TO NOTE THAT, UH, WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO PERMIT TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES, AS IS OUR CUSTOM AND
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK. AFTER THE
PRIMARY SUPPORT. I'LL INVITE
OTHER SUPPORTERS TO STATE THEIR
NAME, THEIR AFFILIATION THE
POSITION I WOULD DO THE SAME FOR
THE OPPOSITION AFTER WE HEAR
FROM SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
TURN TO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU WISH TO FURTHER
EXPOUND ON YOUR POSITION, YOU
CAN SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE USING ONE OF THE
MESSAGES DESCRIBED ON THE JU
SHARED COMMITTEES WEBSITE. ALL
RIGHT. AND UH, FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAY BE, UH, PARTICIPATING,
VIRTUALLY, UH ALL TESTIMONY WILL
BE LIVE AND IN PERSON HERE TODAY
, AND, UH, AND AS WE PROCEED,
UH, THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
REST OF THIS YEAR, ALL RIGHT,
UM, I SEE THAT, UH, SENATOR.
LOLA SMALLWOOD CUEVAS IS HERE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. GOOD AFTERNOON. IT
IS MY GREAT HONOR, UH, TO PUT
BEFORE YOU S¼ èC R 113. THIS IS
THE STATE'S RECOGNITION AND
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
ROLE IN PERPETUATING THE HARMS
AND ONGOING EFFECTS OF SLAVERY
OF BLACK PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
IN THIS NATION. THE RESOLUTION
CONTAINS NUMEROUS FACTUAL CITED
REFERENCES TO EGREGIOUS ACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SLAVERY AND THE
ENDURING INSTITUTIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS AND ENACTMENTS OVER
THE YEARS THAT FURTHER IMPEDE
THE ABILITY OF BLACK
CALIFORNIANS TO LAWFULLY
PARTICIPATE AS FULL MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY. WHILE WE CANNOT FULLY
COMPREHEND THE TOTAL IMPACT AND
MAGNITUDE OF THE LOST
OPPORTUNITY WITHIN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY OVER THE LAST THREE
CENTURIES, AND I WANNA SHOW YOU
WHAT OUR CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE
ON THE STUDY OF THE PROPOSAL OF
DEVELOPMENT OF REPARATIONS. THIS
IS THE SCHOLARSHIP. THESE ARE
THE FINDINGS THAT LAY OUT
EXACTLY HOW OVER CENTURIES.
CALIFORNIA. BASED ON AN AMERICAN
VALUE SYSTEM. ENACTED BRUTALIZED
CHATTEL, SLAVERY AND
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES FOR
AT LEAST 12 GENERATIONS. A BLACK
FAMILIES. SO. I WANT TO SAY THAT
THIS IS SACRED WORK THAT I'M
DOING HERE TODAY. TO ASK THIS
BODY TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE LEAST
THING WE CAN DO TO BEGIN THE
HEALING IS TO RECOGNIZE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THESE FACTS. I DO
NOT HAVE WITNESSES TODAY. UM
WITH ME. UH, BUT I WANT TO, UM,
SIMPLY CLOSE BY SAYING THAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS A FIRST STEP. THAT
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO TODAY, ACKNOWLEDGING
THE NEED FOR REPARATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT THIS IS NOT A
BINDING, UH, DOCUMENT. THIS IS
SIMPLY A RESOLUTION
ACKNOWLEDGING THE FINDINGS,
ACKNOWLEDGING THE WORK OF THE
TASK FORCE. AND BEGINNING TO SET
THE FOUNDATION FOR THE REAL WORK
OF BUILDING LEGISLATION THAT
BEGINS TO REPAIR THE HARM. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES OR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ R 113, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
TASHA STEVENS. I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
CATALYST, CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
REPARATIONS, RECONCILIATION AND
TRUTH. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS MY
NAME IS AALIA KING, ALSO WITH
CAS, CALIFORNIA AND A
CONSTITUENT, A LIFELONG
CONSTITUENT OF, UH SENATOR NEO'S
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT,
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NÓ ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, SEEING NÓ ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE. UM
WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES, SENATOR RAO.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. I MIGHT BE
SPEAKING FOR A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THAN THE AUTHOR DID, BUT IT'S UH
AND THAT'S I THINK QUITE UNUSUAL
, BUT I THINK THIS IS SUCH A
CRITICAL ISSUE THAT I FELT
COMPELLED TO DO SO. UM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TOOK AN ACTIVE
PART. IN PERMITTING, ENACTING
AND ENFORCING LAWS AND POLICIES
THAT HAD THIS MULTIGENERATIONAL
IMPACT TO AFRICAN AMERICANS. THE
STATE PROHIBITED INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGE. THE STATE CONSTRUCTED
MONUMENTS AND PLAQUES,
MEMORIALIZING CONFEDERATE
CULTURE AND GLORIFYING SLAVERY.
THE STATE PERMITTED RACIALLY
RESTRICTED COVENANTS, REDLINING
AND ZONING ORDINANCES THAT STILL
HAVE DAMAGING EFFECTS ON AFRICAN
AMERICANS. HOME OWNERSHIP RATES
TODAY. THE STATE OPENLY ALLOWED
SEGREGATION AND DISCRIMINATION
IN EMPLOYMENT, HOUSING AND
HEALTH CARE POLICIES. THE STATE
TARGETED AFRICAN AMERICANS
THROUGH THEIR USE OF QUOTE
UNQUOTE TOUGH ON CRIME MEASURES.
UH, AND USING CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AND RESULTED IN THE
QUADRUPLING OF THE PRISON
POPULATION. OVER A 20 YEAR
PERIOD. IT IS LONG PAST TIME.
FOR THE STATE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR ROLE AND RESPONSIBILITIES
AND THE ATROCITIES. THEY
ADVANCED. THAT PROMOTED AND
FACILITATED THE INSTITUTION OF
SLAVERY. STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
AND SHOULD CONTINUE TO AFFIRM
ITS ROLE IN PROTECTING AND
UPLIFTING THE DESCENDANTS OF
ENSLAVED PEOPLE. WHO'VE BEEN
HARMED BY A LEGACY OF STATE
SANCTIONED POLICIES. THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK. AND I
THINK THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RASO. OTHER COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UM. WE WE
WILL ONCE ONCE. UH, WE HAVE A
QUORUM SENATOR. ALSO, WE WILL
ACCEPT YOUR MOTION. SO, SENATOR
LAIRD. I OH, OK, SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
AND UH, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEFERENCE. UH, SENATOR, UM I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE, UM, THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS. UM AND THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE BY THE,
UH, COMMITTEE AS WELL. UM. I
THINK THE, UM THE PART THAT
JUMPED OUT AT ME THE MOST WAS
THE, UM HOW PERNICIOUS. UM THE.
THE WORK WAS TO EXCLUDE AFRICAN
AMERICANS. BLACK PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FROM THE
RIGHTS AND PRIVILEGES OF, UM
THOSE THAT WE EXPECT. AND THAT
WE ENJOY AND THAT IT LASTED UP
UNTIL THE SIXTIES. IT'S SHOCKING
. IT'S SHOCKING. UM AND UM AND
WHEN YOU HAVE A LEGAL SYSTEM
THAT IS SET UP TO, UM, DENY
RIGHTS. AND TO EXCLUDE PEOPLE
AND TO, UH, TARGET THEM. IN A
WAY THAT, UM, THAT HAS LASTING
IMPACT WAY BEYOND SLAVERY. WAY
BEYOND SLAVERY. UM IT'S UM IT'S
REALLY DISTURBING AND I AND I
SAY THAT HAVING, UM, I'M ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT I BECAME AN
ATTORNEY WAS TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE WHO FELT LIKE THEY
HAD NÓ CHOICE IN THEIR LIFE. UH,
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW THE
LAW WORKED. AND UM, AND ON THE
THEORY THAT IF YOU JUST KNEW HOW
THE LAW WORKED, THEN IT WOULD BE
FAIR. BUT IF IT'S SET UP AGAINST
YOU DOESN'T MATTER HOW MANY
DEFENDERS YOU HAVE. YOU'RE STILL
GOING TO END UP ON THE LOSING
END. AND SO, UM, TO REALIZE HOW
HOW LONG IT TOOK TO GET
AMENDMENTS PASSED. UM I YOU KNOW
MY I. I KNEW THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA BEING A NON SLAVE
OWNING STATE. AND THERE'S A BOOK
THAT'S WRITTEN ABOUT THE UM,
LATINO COMMUNITY IN PARTICULAR
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY,
UM, BEING ON THE SIDE OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE CIVIL WAR, SO
YOU KNOW THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE
THAT BELIEVED IN THE RIGHTS OF
ALL HUMANS. UM BUT THAT THE
STATE WAS STILL ACTING. UM UM,
WITH WITH INTENT IS REALLY
DISTURBING. SO I APPRECIATE UM,
UM, THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
AND, UM AND I'LL I'LL OBVIOUSLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IS
FORWARD. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CABELLO. UM, LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM HERE BEFORE WE GET MUCH
FURTHER, MADAM SECRETARY, WOULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL? HAMBURG.
HUMBERG HERE. WILK ALLEN. ASHBY
ASHBY HERE, CABALLERO CABALLERO
HERE, TOO, TO RAZO HERE, LAIRD.
LAYERED HERE. MEN NELO NELO
HERE, STERN. W. A HUB HERE. E, A
QUORUM. ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE A
QUORUM. AND I KNOW SENATOR DE
ROSSA. YOU WANT TO MAKE A MOTION
SENATOR ALSO HAS MOVED THE BILL,
SENATOR LAIRD. I WANT TO MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT AND I WANTED TO
ADD ON TO UH, WHAT THE SENATOR
JUST SAID, AND IT I READ THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY. I HAVE YET TO
READ THAT FULL VOLUME. IT'S
POWERFUL. AND. WHILE THERE'S
BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
LEGALITIES, SOME OF US ARE OLD
ENOUGH TO HAVE EXPERIENCED SOME
OF THESE THINGS IN DAY WE LIFE
IN THE SENSE THAT WHEN I WAS AT
MY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, YOU COULD
LOOK FROM THE PLAYGROUND. JUST
FOUR DOORS DOWN AND ACROSS THE
STREET WAS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
NEIGHBORHOOD. BUT THEY WEREN'T
DRAWN. I IN THE SAME LINE TO BE
WITH OUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. AND
IT IT WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I WON A SPEECH CONTEST REGULARLY
FROM THE ELKS CLUB, BUT THE ELKS
CLUB HAD TWO IN OUR TOWN, ONE
THAT DISCRIMINATED AND ONE THAT
DIDN'T SO THE ONE THAT DIDN'T
WAS 98% AFRICAN AMERICAN. THE
ONE THAT DID WAS 100% WHITE THAT
JUST WENT ON AS A NORMAL ORDER
OF THINGS AS WE DID THINGS. I
MEAN, MY FATHER, WHO WAS NOT
VERY POLITICAL, PUT A NÓ ON THE
REPEAL OF THE RUMP FOR HOUSING
ACT STICKER ON THE CAR. AND YOU
THOUGHT THAT WE HAD DECLARED WAR
ON ALL OUR NEIGHBORS, AND SO IT
IT'S LIKE THIS WAS AN
EXPERIENCE. THIS WASN'T JUST THE
LEGAL THIS IS WHAT WAS GOING ON
CULTURALLY A, A AND AROUND, AND
SO I THINK THAT THIS STEP IN
THIS RESOLUTION IS IMPORTANT.
THE FIRST STEP. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE I THINK IT
REALLY MEANS SOMETHING TO
ANYBODY THAT HAS EXPERIENCED
THAT. AND OF COURSE, PEOPLE WERE
EXPERIENCING IT TO THIS VERY
DAY. BUT NEVERTHELESS I JUST
APPRECIATE YOU FOR BRINGING IT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
THE MOTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. IT'S CERTAINLY
TRUE THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS COUNTRY AND
HAVE BEEN DISADVANTAGED. UM I.
WELL I DON'T OPPOSE THIS
RESOLUTION, BUT NEITHER CAN I
SUPPORT IT. FOR TWO REASONS.
NUMBER ONE, EVEN THOUGH IT ISN'T
BINDING. I'M TROUBLED BY THE
FACT THAT IT IT COULD BE GRABBED
ON TO BY CERTAIN ATTORNEYS THAT
PRACTICE IN THIS STATE THAT
COULD UTILIZE THAT AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS LIABILITY SUIT. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, WHAT JUMPED OUT TO
ME IN THE RESOLUTION WAS WHAT
DIDN'T JUMP OUT TO ME. WHAT IS
EXCLUDED? AND IN MY OPINION
CONSIDERABLY COMPROMISES.
AFRICAN AMERICANS. FROM
OVERCOMING THESE ISSUES. IS THE
ABJECT FAILURE. OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM. CASE THROUGH 12 SYSTEM.
UM. IN A RECENT ARTICLE BY CAL
MATTERS. AND, UH, 2020 THREE.
UH, BLACK STUDENTS HAD THE
LOWEST LEVEL. OF ACHIEVEMENT AND
ACCOMPLISHMENT. IN THE STATE. IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS FULLY, UM
UH, WELL, 64% FULLY 36% LESS
THAN ALL STUDENTS. AND 54% LESS
THAN ALL STUDENTS IN MATH. THIS
CERTAINLY IS NOT BECAUSE OF
NATIVE ABILITY. THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT. NOR IS IT UH
BECAUSE OF ANY POOR PUPIL
SPENDING PER PUPIL PER PUPIL
SPENDING HAS INCREASED. OVER 6%
A YEAR FROM THE TIME THAT I LEFT
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN I WAS
TERMED OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY, AND
THAT'S DURING A TIME PERIOD WHEN
INFLATION WAS VIRTUALLY ZERO.
THE ABJECT FAILURE. OF THE Kò
THROUGH 12 SYSTEM. TO PROVIDE
THE SAME QUALITY OF EDUCATION TO
BLACK STUDENTS. AS TO, UH WHITE
STUDENTS AND OTHER STUDENTS. UH,
IS A FAILURE THAT I COULD ALMOST
CHARACTERIZE AS SCANDALOUS AND
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME. THAT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE ARE ABLE
TO DO RELATIVE TO PAST PRACTICES
AND AGAIN. CERTAINLY AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
DISADVANTAGED. DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST. BUT IN FORWARD LOOKING
IN TERMS OF OPPORTUNITIES,
UNLESS WE FIX THIS. UNLESS WE
FIX THE FAILURE OF ARCADE
THROUGH 12 SYSTEM TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF BLACK STUDENTS. AND THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF BLACK STUDENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE. TO
STRUGGLE WITH THIS. AND I'D
WELCOME HAVING A SEPARATE
DISCUSSION. WITH YOU, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AS TO WHAT
COULD BE DONE ABOUT THAT. BUT I
THINK THAT IS. PERHAPS
OVERRIDING, IMPORTANT RELATIVE
TO FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
BLACK CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS. UH,
LET ME LET ME JUST, UM FIRST LET
ME RESPOND TO SENATOR NELO ON A
COUPLE OF POINTS. UH, I. I
APPRECIATE YOU POINTING OUT THE
DISPARITY IN TERMS OF
OPPORTUNITY AND EDUCATION. UM,
THE DISPARITIES IS, I'M SURE
SENATOR SMALLY CUEVAS IS GONNA
POINT OUT EXIST IN MANY OTHER
AREAS AS WELL. THERE'S
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYMENT. UM OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN EDUCATION THAT
THAT ALL NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IN TERMS
OF YOUR POINT CONCERNING
LIABILITY. I THINK WHAT WE DO
TODAY CREATES LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY AND LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
UH, SENATOR SMALL. CUEVAS
POINTED OUT IN HER OPENING THAT
THAT THIS IS NOT INTENDED DOES
NOT CREATE LIABILITY ON THE PART
OF THE STATE, AND I THINK THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE EIGHT. ALSO
FURTHER, UM ILLUSTRATES THAT AND
SETS THAT OUT. UM THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. UM I. I
AM CONCERNED THAT CALIFORNIANS
DON'T KNOW OF OUR OWN LEGACY,
OUR OWN HISTORY. I'M CONCERNED
THAT IT'S NOT TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS.
I AM CONCERNED THAT OTHER STATES
TODAY ARE TRYING TO DENY THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE HISTORY OF SLAVERY AND IT
AND IT'S, UH IMPLICATIONS BOTH
THEN AND NOW. UM AND I'M PROUD
OF THE FACT THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE BEGINNING THAT
PROCESS, THE PROCESS TO AT LEAST
RECOGNIZE OUR HISTORY AND TEACH
OUR HISTORY SO THAT, UH, YOUNG
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE LEGACY.
UH, THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
GROW. IT'S THE ONLY WAY WE CAN.
WE CAN HEAL. UM AND THIS IS NOT
JUST SOMETHING A REMNANT FROM
THE ANCIENT PAST. I MEAN, THIS
CONTINUES ITS CENTER. LAIRD
POINTS OUT THAT THAT THAT IN OUR
OWN LIVED EXPERIENCE IN MY OWN
LIVED EXPERIENCE. I PROSECUTED
SKINHEADS FOR BRINGING IT ACROSS
ON THE FRONT LAWN OF AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN FAMILY IN WESTMINSTER,
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DRIVING THEM OUT OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD. THAT WAS A FEW
YEARS AGO. BUT IT WAS IN, YOU
KNOW, IN OUR LIFETIME, CERTAINLY
WITHIN OUR LIFETIMES, AND SO,
UH, THAT THAT LEGACY THAT LEGACY
CONTINUES. SO II I COMMEND YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS I COMMEND YOU
FOR, UM, MAKING SURE THAT THAT
THAT WE AS A BODY. WE SPEAK AS A
POLICY MAKING BODY NOW FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE AND, UM
AND MOVE FORWARD. SO HAVING SAID
THAT, UM OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS DID YOU WANNA CLOSE,
SENATOR? SMALL CUEVAS? WELL,
FIRST I WANNA THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SUCH RICH
PERSONAL ACCOUNTS. UM BUT ALSO,
UH, YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA LEADING THE WAY ON
ENSURING A PROCESS BY WHICH WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARMS OF THE
PAST. AND WE RECOGNIZE HOW THOSE
HARMS THE INSTITUTIONAL.
FOOTPRINT THAT'S LEFT BY THOSE
HARMS IMPACT SO MANY COMMUNITIES
WELL BEYOND THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
IT IS TIME AS YOU SAID, UH,
SENATOR DE RUSSO. IT IS TIME FOR
US TO ADDRESS OUR PAST. AND AS
YOU SAY, UH, MR CHAIR AND THOSE
WHO DON'T KNOW THE HISTORY ARE
DOOMED TO REPEAT IT. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. IT'S ABOUT
SETTING CALIFORNIA ON A PATHWAY
FORWARD THAT SAYS WE DO NOT
BELIEVE IN THIS LEVEL OF RACISM
AND DISCRIMINATION, BRUTAL AND
BRUTALIZED. ECON ECONOMIC
DISENFRANCHISEMENT. THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
DO BETTER AND LEAVE THE PAST
BEHIND. THAT'S WHAT THIS, UH
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT IS TODAY THAT WE
ARE READY TO START TO START A
PATH THAT RECOGNIZES THE HARMS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, UH, SENATOR DE RAO HAS
MOVED THE RESOLUTION. MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE S¼ R 113. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED
AMBERG. UM, I WILK ALAN. ASHBY
ASHBY, I CABALLERO CABALLERO, I
DURAO DURAZO. I LAYERED LAYERED
I MIN MILO. WHAT HAPPENED?
WAHAB. I. 6 TO 0 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. WE'RE GOING. WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
HERE FOR A FEW MOMENTS. UM THIS
IS THE ONLY MATTER THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US HERE TODAY. UM I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT SOME
MEMBERS ARE IN THE BUILDING AND
SOME MEMBERS ARE NOT AVAILABLE
TO VOTE, BUT WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN HERE FOR A LITTLE
WHILE. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
UM WILK, ALAN, ALAN. I MIN NELO.
SEVEN TO 070 GONNA PUT IT BACK
ON CALL FOR A FEW MORE MOMENTS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN.
MADAM SECRETARY, IF YOU WOULD
OPEN THE ROLL. WILK. MEN. MILO
STERN STERN EYE. EIGHT TO 08 TO
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED,
UM WE'RE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.